[Musique]
quel serait papa le compte de la misère
par exemple eh bien ça serait de boire
de l'eau chaude parce que j'ai pas les
moyens de nous payer à sa chérie tu es à
huy pour l'asiatique c'était rituel
c'est effrayant effrayant et pourtant ça
existe
j'aimerais vivre ou
je vois je pense que j'aimerais
retourner en chine jeu
finir mes jours en chine comment ça
pulse en chine c'est quoi ton idéal de
bonheur terrestre
idéal de bonheur terrestre c'est
adele a sûrement dit
et pour quelle faute à tu le plus
l'injustice
pour
les personnes qui
qui savent bien mentir oui oui
parce que généralement personnes qui
savent bien mentir elles savent bien à
vous aussi
assez facilement or ce que c'est
c'est assez vite par doom est monté à
glasgow
oui
pas longtemps comment tu voudrais mourir
j'espère mourir
ducasse ben non c'est pas du jeu reprend
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu